hello hello can you hear us can you hear
us we want to make sure this is going ok
this time run the output right yeah this
is the one what are you talking about or
what are you gauging input is what you
want yes ok really well put it on what
the move you can hear us correctly right
loud and clear what's going on people
how are you how are you so we're gonna
make this an efficient live stream I
know we always say that we scream for an
hour and a half but I got a collab
scheduled later today over Olivia my
girlfriend who's in the chat right now
my needs surgery and if that's the case
I gotta cancel everything and jet over
to her face off this emergency situation
pray she doesn't need surgery everyone
pray yeah the more you like and comment
the less surgeries you'll need yeah
exactly
I believe in positive energy so make
sure do it I love you too James yeah you
guys are all great listen it's the last
day of the month and there's one more
patron the day shout out that we did not
do before the month is over and that's
going out to Luke Anderson right now
Luke we're live unedited shout out for
you buddy what I remember about you
since we haven't talked in a while is
that you are like Tom Hanks from
castaway except you don't [ __ ] up on
your job and you actually get things
done hard worker
leader dad is religious but you're not
religious well you kind of are I don't
know we'll complete it more of a better
shout out towards the end of this guy's
Batman is not gonna be Ben Affleck
anymore isn't that exciting stuff
doesn't that suck so wait a minute you
mean Batman is gonna stop playing Ben
Affleck in real life yeah so who's gonna
be Ben Affleck now Matt Damon's yeah
that's a that's big news that was we
already kind of knew well I think it is
official like I was talking with my lady
yesterday and she was saying that like
it's official I couldn't find anything
but then I saw that Ben Affleck
retweeted something about from deadline
that what the headline was about how
he's not gonna be Batman anymore and he
was pretty much like ye up well this is
some exciting news John which we should
have had channel or movie news
personality well what are your thoughts
on this I mean I think you're gonna vote
on this target place in a big way cinema
landscape any Hoffman thinks it's a new
home I mean you know any super Chet's
that come and I'm just gonna screenshot
them and make sure to get to your
questions thanks Tiffany Hoffman we will
get to you in a second Shawn please
continue oh my goodness how did John
Campea handle these super chats I don't
know I don't know what this is gonna do
I feel like yeah I mean we kind of
already had this this theory in mind
that he wasn't gonna return after the
miserable experience it seemed like it
was for him well I think it's safe to
say we all knew Ben Affleck would not be
returning due to his alcoholic ways his
obvious lashing out in a
passive-aggressive way in interviews
about fandom and everything so it's
pretty obvious Ben Affleck was indeed
not going to return there plus if he's
just not happy doing it I don't want him
to be doing it that said hey Andres the
warden greetings to you my friend up
screenshotting before it gets too big
what sucks is you know Ben Affleck I did
think was great in BVS it's funny
because he was someone who a lot of
people were talking so much [ __ ] on and
I remember we did a video about it
before this channel was popular at all
we did a video about it and and we were
I think we were in support of it yeah I
mean you know it's that argument of like
we how many controversial castings for
superhero movies have turned out alright
you know I bet this will be probably
fine anything Batman the best part of
BBS he was she was the best part of BBS
and we all it's just this is officially
confirmed that he's not going to be
reprising the role for Matt Reeves
specifically because honestly I we were
doing a yeah okay let's go let's try to
be a little more sincere now let's
switch out of sarcasm movie news mode in
this sincerity
we were doing a QA recently and I'm
really loving how the DC EU or whatever
the [ __ ] they call it is is expanding
and what what it's shaping up to be I
love how there are two biggest films
right now are as Wonder Woman Aquaman
Aquaman being the face of DC which is
such a weird thing as something that's
really unexpected Benjamin Warren okay
while we're getting some unexpected
super chests thanks guys I'm
screenshotting all of them we will
answer your questions at the end yeah I
was I I really like that we're getting
such a distinct variety of films like it
seems like that thing that was really
criticized of how they were kind of
rushing to be like in the mashups and
the team-ups and that a course
correction is drastically working in
their favor I love that Aquaman and
Wonder Woman feel so different from one
another
Shazam feels different than those films
this standalone Joker origin movie it's
gonna be R rated I'm excited for the
birds of prey even at 20 cities that
kind of had this like and a pyramid like
neon kind of vibe to it
I really I'm really diggin what where
the DC is shifting towards and
everything they're doing now and then
they're saying Batman's gonna be like a
new AR detective film something that
we've heard Matt Reeves comment on
several times in this film especially
has a release date so I'm excited to see
what they gear up for in this film I
feel like no one's really bought any
more that you know Ben Affleck is not
gonna be in it because I think we've all
kind of prepped ourselves for that Thank
You Corey thanks Clash thanks Justin
okay don't worry we will answer all
these wow you guys are being very
supportive right now thank you all these
live streamers will be DC I don't suck
all your dicks later don't you guys
worry okay so and and I guess like when
it come I'm more excited for the
director what's cool about this is
before it was like been athis gonna star
director it--in now he's not doing
anything yeah but the way DC is kind of
working especially the fact that they
have a standalone joke or origin movie
it kind of makes me wonder are they
doing are they like shaping up some type
of Elseworlds thing could Ben Affleck's
Batman still kind of exist as an older
Batman and then you kind of have a
different actor playing Batman either
a younger version maybe it is modern
daytime or it's an Elseworlds version
you know that's that's kind of where I'm
I feel like DC's kind of study
themselves over they can kind of do
anything now yeah I mean my theory on
this and I just hope that it's true I
don't know if it's true at all because
again the to accept ibly agreeably good
DC movies have been to movies that are
groundbreaking in a way but our very
superhero movie at the end of the day
and and I feel like what I'm hoping
their theory is moving forward is we're
gonna make our universe a lot more
modular than the Marvel Universe instead
of trying to fast forward into what
Marvel is I feel like maybe with all
these weirdly disconnected things on
their slate
maybe that's the direction they're gonna
go and crossover occasionally but have a
lot of different contains stories that
get to be their own little universes and
that could set them apart from Marble
right and it could make it less
devastating every time an installment
maybe doesn't go the way they hoped I
feel like I'm Way past the whole
discussion now of like making sure you
set yourself apart from Marvel and all
these things I feel like with Wonder
Woman and Aquaman they've already done
that the fact that those two movies are
the face of the DC Universe now I feel
like they've already succeeded even
think it's just such a strange thing for
Jason Momoa to be the the main face now
DC Universe and I'll good it's kind of
like Iron Man and Tony and Robert Downey
jr. being the face of the MCU
robbed on Jews personally fits really
well with who Tony Stark is from the
comics whereas Jason Momoa is is so
different from Aquaman yet he's
redefined it in the cinematic landscape
and welcomed his character needed more
help I mean they basically made Aquaman
just to heighten Jason Momoa and I like
Jason Momoa I mean I love that weirdness
about it I'm loving what what DC is
currently slating up to do I like even
that I used to kind of be annoyed by the
announcements of the bat world stuff
without having Batman in it but now I've
kind of shifted into this guy who's
who's really loving like oh that's cool
having a birds-of-prey movie without
Batman being
focus in it but having all these
characters that exists within the bad
world that is so unique for a universe
expansion to do that already just by
committing to this arena separates
itself from Marvel and and already I
really have already successfully done it
and separating themselves with Wonder
Woman I agree with you with Aquaman not
so much just because I feel like Marvel
could have easily made that movie it's
not very Oh Wonder Woman for the first
two acts tries to hint and a larger and
it is like Captain America in a way but
at least breaks ground in one way Marvel
did not which was you know with thanks
with diversity and representation but I
love that the face of the DC movies are
not generic white people - oh yeah
that's nice I mean I there they broke
ground they've got an Israeli lady and a
Samoan guy so that's cool now I'm down
which gets me excited for who is gonna
who's gonna replace Batman no no Tom
Hardy all right Cassie is the main
option for everything I know there's
probably gonna be a lot of Jake
Gyllenhaal's to go Jake Gyllenhaal all
the time you know people always say that
but diversity
I died that's what we need that's all
that matters
are you about to jokingly bark up a
pretty good tree no in herself ax would
write he'd be great that dude in crazy
rich Asians I feel like would be a great
Superman or Batman
sure the main guy there thanks Justin
people be saying Oscar Isaac yeah of
course good actor first good white boy I
don't think he's like Mexican or
something leave white Henry Golding
that's the [ __ ] today that's who
I was talking about
I don't even care if there are good
actors as long as it's diverse go to
Chinatown and grab an Asian guy off the
street oh yeah put in his bad man and
we're happy people diversity the guy who
was in you know like the GI Joe movie I
think and and the other one I have it I
have his name but I oh they're the
Magnificent Seven
the guy from Magnificent Seven remake
Chris Pratt nanny Chris proud week great
know Chris Pratt Denzel Washington would
be perfect perfect choices okay I feel
like John Hamm should be Superman
perhaps I mean I mean if they're if they
were going for a younger bad man I don't
feel like jon Hamm's the direction to go
guys well I've had worked ok we will
circle back to all the thoughts and
opinions on the bat movie I'm excited
for it Matt Reeves has been gearing up
for it and the successfully reiterated
what he's doing with the film for two
years now that's exciting
James Gunn apparently we all saw this
coming to these announcements that
everyone's freaking out about are things
we all saw coming James Gunn officially
directing Suicide Squad - that is not a
surprise right and if he's taken like
misfit villainy characters and turning
them into kind of heroes I mean he wrote
and directed that movie for Marvel's so
why wouldn't he write and direct it for
us it all goes hand in hand right it it
all goes hand in hand with the
interesting direction that DC's kind of
taking with revamping some things but
also not completely starting from
scratch like oh no we're still gonna
keep wonderful in an Aquaman but we're
gonna remove that man you already had a
demon and we're gonna revamp Suicide
Squad but we're also gonna do birds of
prey so Harley Quinn still exists here
with Margot Robbie but she might not be
in Suicide Squad too because it's gonna
be a whole different kind of crew in
this time around so it's it's a little
bit confusing but I'm so fascinated by
how everything's going to sort of shape
up and turn out to be because is it
you're gonna be confusing for audiences
we were like wait a minute this
completely revamped because I swear I
saw Aquaman and Wonder Woman those two
adders with a Batman already yeah I will
take I will gladly take the confusion
over these sort of like I can see
exactly what you're trying to do and
it's and you're not doing it within EMS
I would rather have a thing to figure
out that's maybe interesting you know
and kind of different and has variety to
where you know that this isn't riding on
everything is part of same thing so if
one's bad it's actually not that
catastrophic
yeah exactly I'm excited for what James
Gunn's gonna do with this yeah I think
he's kind of the perfect I mean I
thought David Ayer was a good guy for
the job too but I think he's even good
or guy for the job
look you can an Arabian guy to play
Batman and then you go hardcore with
Suicide Squad too by introducing a lot
of James Gunn's pedophile jokes and we
got solid material that only the Suicide
Squad as they're all pedophilia
and then we'll blame it on you if the
mission goes you know it's a weird time
to be alive I do think James Gunn is a
it would do a fantastic job with Suicide
Squad - I really do
I really I do feel like you should have
had a meeting with Disney like something
that should have been discussed as
opposed to just canning and I'm good
school that Warner Brothers that would
be so cool James Gunn can go back to
that like an r-rated film oh that would
be awesome
yeah with more of those pedophile jokes
well that'll be the villain is Twitter
you know is they have to go back and
expunge all their tweets yeah then they
can't and Steppenwolf is back and he
gets ahold of the tweets yeah you know
and there you go that's disseminates
them throughout the universe that's
great stuff man
well thank you I'm excited for where
DC's turning into let's keep this open
over here guys are gonna go over some of
the super jets that we got because
normally we only get like one or two and
then like a few you guys have
contributed to the super chat quite a
bit so thank you
Tiffany Hoffman was our first one she
said I want to know if Howard the Duck
going to ever get a reboot
can you ever successfully properly do a
Howard the Duck reboot though what makes
it so special as how terrible that first
one was it's gained a cult following
over time that if you try to replicate
it in any capacity or try to make it
good it's just I feel like it would just
overall totally miss the mark if you did
that John what are your thoughts on a
Howard the Duck reboot actually I think
this could work you get Phil Lord and
Chris Miller to write it Andy Serkis to
direct it you're gold there's you know
what movie fight won but you did it John
this man just mocap that duck in your
bill and you slap the Lord and Chris
Miller or anything then we're a oak and
they can take things that shouldn't work
in and make them work oh I missed a
question oh I missed the name I totally
when there was a bunch coming in someone
I'm sorry front of shun your name out
properly we need to figure out how to
just review the super someone say I'm
sure we'll find it like after the live
stream is done hi real rejects who do
you want as a new Lex if we can recast
that role that easily I was so with fun
board for I have a collab set up at 1:30
and I feel like I was gonna blow all my
undersea oh that's a lot of stream
before that collab at who do you want as
a new legs I was way on board for Bryan
Cranston to be a new Lex I know that the
I just happened where the Heisenberg
beanie but I know the bald look
automatically associates him with
Heisenberg Walter White and bring bad
but I always felt that he would be a
perfect Lex Luthor and in my opinion see
that's where I would put like an Oscar
Isaac or something like that like shave
his head see how that goes because I
feel like Bryan Cranston is a good
choice but I also feel like I've seen
him do I feel like I've seen him do what
his Lex
there might be and then they'll just
have a new name on it Oh interesting
where is yeah like somebody like that
who's like okay you've been around for a
little while you're established or maybe
more manly or just more mature than a
Jesse Eisenberg but you got the
intensity in the chops I think he could
do it sure sure I think I think it would
be a fantastic one and let me see maybe
I did it properly on a different one
clash with the Spree says what do you
think of Legion of Super Pets movie that
sounds growl about it oh wait Legion of
Super Pets I forget it someone a someone
already attached to that movie I don't
know live stream why don't we just ask
the good crowd here someone already
attached to direct that movie or write
that movie because I know it's yeah it's
like I got like a cow bat or something
like that it's like this weird as they I
think that's cool I've even that obscure
issue or Batman has a farm well I think
with you know going back to Phil Lord
and Chris Miller and and also with the
spider versus proven with Lord Chris
mother's involvement in there I think
that probably see a lot more of these I
heard about the Batman Beyond animated
movie that they're working on that's
which I'm very excited for I loved that
many almond when I was a kid and I have
always thought that it would be I've
always wanted a live-action version of
Batman Beyond but I feel like you've
really got a build to that yeah and
unfortunately we always end the
franchises or replace the actors really
we're never gonna properly get there but
I think you might be kind of neat if
they decide to do a live-action Batman
Beyond and you brought that Affleck back
for that are you pretty sweet if they
did that
that would be cool yeah I mean Ben
Affleck's Batman yeah I want I really
want him to have a chance to shine if he
ever comes back cuz he was I liked his
Batman and Sue in BBS and stuff but even
then I don't think he really got a
chance to shine you know saw CB don't
worry we'll get to you buddy
yeah I think okay so Justin bad that bad
bad help but L too felt do you think
athlete can come maybe since this is a
young Batman he's only temporary leaving
I doubt it shorts considered though well
it's kind of what we were talking about
the top Justin of the idea that it might
be Elseworlds
or if it is a younger version you could
still keep older Batman but from what
manner Yves has said about that there
will be a rose gallery already and that
Batman will have already been an
established superhero that it kind of
makes the time like it's kind of its
kind of the How I Met Your Mother
problem where for some reason the actor
who plays Ted eventually turns into
who's the guy who does the voiceover
power especially when we see him older
later because their ever younger version
you get a Batman oh you got an 18 year
old situation more like the older
characters actually younger actors yeah
we're too late to make this might be a
little a little strange
I think but like Bennet Ben Affleck for
like a like an old Batman I think about
if they are committing to because like
if you have the Harley Quinn still
sticking around right if you have Harley
Quinn is margot robbie obviously still
sticking around then that that means
that Jared Leto's Joker can still
definitely exist they said he exists but
he can most likely still exist and then
you have the walking Phoenix Joker one
so what I feel like you can have two
Batman's in there it sounds [ __ ]
weird but you know it's cool Jenna
Randolph I did I just replied to you on
patreon earlier thanks for being here we
will answer your question in just a
second we need know how to monitor these
better like a menu I've seen people do
it and I don't know how greetings you
too from Andrus the warrior high alpha
he says oh we are way out of focus yeah
get the focus what's happening with the
focus oh there it is greetings you two
big fan enjoyed watching your videos
plus how about this Ben Affleck as Isaac
Clark for dead space think about it
honor to meet you oh man let's just
pretend we know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about I mean dead space is a
survival horror sci-fi video game and I
assume that Isaac Clark is the lead
and that cuz I'm mad as much as me now
yeah I've been hoping weirdly enough
I've been hoping that they make a dead
space movie because that's a combination
of ideas I really like a Isaac Clark
from dead space here and see what he
looks like
I like this the silence of a live stream
which is so so gripping now man it's
it's real I mean I would need to be more
familiar to properly know but I feel
like Ben Affleck is can kind of blend
into almost any genre you know he's an
actor who used to just suck but now he's
like such a cool actor now owe me by I
don't know if I feel like he could blend
into any genre just cuz I haven't seen
him do a bunch of dude he was an
autistic accountant who was yeah man
very accurate and not a fan of you know
you can do action and dramas and you
know comic-book stuff but like I've
never seen him in an all-out sci-fi or
an all-out horror movie or he's not that
into you scene stealer so great sci-fi
dude I don't wanna close my eyes oh yeah
I don't wanna follow animal crackers on
ya on eros my daughter I think he would
be pert I feel like for anything action
related he could do great action action
I think is a great action actor
especially after like the town the town
man was just awesome
justice is I have real autism and I
loved athletes performance represent man
that's what I'm talking about are
awesome dude hey I mean that should be
the community speaking up I guess the
most yeah on the topic offering opinions
about it okay I was just making sure
we're going through the super chats here
oh gosh it's sometimes when you
screenshot these you miss them a little
bit benjamin Witten says who do you guys
think will take up the cow you know I
saw something going around for Armie
Hammer there's a lot of people going for
that armie hammer I would not want arme
hammer to play Batman I'm sorry I just
would not want
I like I like army hammer but III don't
know if I would choose him don't worry
Jenna we did not miss your question we
just got a few to go through here
Benjamin who do you think would take a
okay
honest answer who I think would be a
good that man take up the mantle
I would like as much as I was making
jokes and then cracks about diversity I
do think that uh [ __ ] and Henry
Golding would be a cool interesting
Batman to take up you need someone who
is dark though I don't really see the
dark side of him but I feel like actors
generally would be you they're probably
trained enough to learn how to do the
darker elements of performances you know
yeah yeah yeah I think that's a good
call actually who I want to be the new
Batman that's a tricky one
Logan Marshall green Logan Marshall crew
would be a great Batman actually perfect
yeah I would love to see that that's a
great call I'm just I'm gonna make him
my I always pitch this guy for
everything he's my eat yourself he's
Eurasia undersell before that capacity
okay I'm trying to get all the questions
here organized because I don't know how
to properly work this all right Jenna
Randall says what about a new bat woman
well don't we already have Ruby Rose and
there is that woman and I thought people
were liking her people like Ruby Rose on
tea while they drove her off the social
media for yeah people drove drive people
off social media all the time thing to
get used to you know what I do hope
which is just a side note but I would
love it if because he said the Batman is
just a working title
and I would adore it if they just called
a Detective Comics because you know like
Detective Comics yes it's where the old
Batman comics came from what about a
dart Detective oh sure that works too
why would I feel like calling a
Detective Comics it would confuse people
you need Batman in the title but I like
the idea of comics in the title I like
the idea of Detective being in the title
I just Detective Comics is an actual
thing so I was just like oh yeah that's
source material so like cool call it
that but but I get you it doesn't EDC
mean Detective Comics
oh is that what that means or Dick Clark
one of the teachers
I don't know might be maybe there yeah I
mean guys this isn't DC stick well
Justin that big guy who did super chat
that of DC stands for Detective Comics
well there you go I learned a piece of
history today John yeah the dark you
have got a prep this is why we had it
yes this detail was was the one that I
should have been looking up all along
but yeah as far as a new bad woman I
think introducing bad woman into the
movies would be a cool idea I don't know
who you would get to play as bad woman
but Meryl Streep Meryl Streep could do
anything guys the Emily Blunt put her in
there as a new bat woman Ronda Rousey
Gina Carano the two actresses we know
who are kind of actresses and also fight
you can also fight though you know you
know who I think would be really cool
Becky Lynch from WWE would be a great
man woman man she is tough as nails if
you guys know what I am my ladies super
into that woman and rightfully so she is
she's [ __ ] awesome
so WWE fans I'm saying Becky Lynch for
the new bat woman right there it's my
girlfriend watching still woman speak up
in the chat if you are ok I don't have
the name here but whoever it is and I
think Michael B Jordan would be
interesting as a younger version of
Batman maybe pull it bad and be honest
understand alone type movie like Joker's
Michael B Jordans the other name that's
kind of thrown around a lot to be this
to be daddy everybody yeah be everybody
and I like honestly yeah Michael B
Jordan would probably be a great Batman
I like a younger Batman I feel like he
could pull it off do what I want him to
do it probably not though that's just
the thing do I agree he would be good
yeah but I all of the madmen be almost I
think yeah I think that Marion is where
it clicks reworking Harry yeah yeah it's
like I feel like he could step into
Bruce Wayne and make it great but I just
can't imagine it yeah it makes any sense
well Terry someone who does come from
more the rougher side of the tracks and
I think Michael B Jordan could pull that
off really well and filling in the
mantle you would be doing as Adonis
Creed
but I do agree with that remember I had
that question siding I wasn't able to
capture your name there in time but
thank you for for contributing here true
tree crew 27 says no one can be a better
Batman than Christian Bale I feel like
people have kind of forgotten that
Christian Bale is an amazing Batman he's
like this is such a great Bruce Wayne if
you the thing is he did Batman Begins
and he's incredible in that film and
then he does Dark Knight which I still
think he's great in but everyone knows
he's outshine by Heath Ledger and then
Dark Knight Rises I think he does a
great job in it as well but you've kind
of just expected him to do his job there
yeah if you go back to Batman Begins it
always reminds you like damn he is a
great Bruce Wayne and the great Batman
he really is and I and and because of
how long ago like that's the first movie
in that series and it's scale is just
not as huge the other ones I feel like
it's kind of easy to forget about his
performance in that particular movie
because you know you've got a lot of set
pieces from the sequels to worry about
sure that's true that's very true John
saucy boy we just we just answered his
didn't we yes we did and what else do we
got here oh oh but that yeah yeah yeah
two questions don't do you think African
come maybe since its young back when we
already answer that one and they all say
be guys in the teaser for boys with Karl
Urban any interest as I think it'll be
great guys we are going to do a live
reaction here here we go I went to
Twitter not YouTube boys with Karl Urban
the boys Karl Urban all right live
reaction time make sure to sync up with
us
this video is now G monetized whoa this
was a superhero show this is like a
watch bin vibe each and every day Wow
cool I've never heard of this that was
cool it does have like a you know not
the slow self-indulgent melancholy
somber tone of Watchmen snappy punchy
like edgy rhythm yeah oh dude it's like
I was like a satire or something like
that it seems I mean it may very well be
kind of deconstructed in a way I feel
like Carla is just the most underrated
badass of all time his name came to mind
when I was thinking about going back
into it was so underrated and that's a
guy who I got a like for some reason
when dread happened that they really
stood out to me that he was like no I
don't think mask off the whole movie
like that's how the character are to be
and something about that I was like good
on you Karl Urban and also you could
totally play like a Batman type
character cuz he's got the weight and
the gruff and he's also got a bit of a
you know an older like he's not an old
guy but he's been around yeah he's
clearly you know capable of kicking an
ass I have never heard of this but that
like visually for you know there's a lot
of the streaming war talk going on and I
feel like Amazon's really gearing up to
like really be a major factor here
because especially we're looking at
the budget for this and the effects it
looks great like this looks like my kind
of show just a heart our snappy [ __ ]
rhythm there is even some elements that
kind of had like a little bit of a
horror aesthetic and it's visual flair
oh yeah I mean it was an intriguing
trailer because it's it's it's just a
montage you know and it makes you wonder
at first like is that guy like a real
superhero and then finally when like
that truck crashes and it's a great it's
just a nice trailer in general because
I'm I don't know what the context really
is of any of this but the tone and
characters in the world all looks like
really cool and appealing yeah yeah like
maybe dark and sinister a little bit but
also like fun and edgy and yeah well and
I appreciate when people do that with
villainy because villainy is scary so
that makes a lot of sense
Brandon parks says athlete can be an
older Batman in a Nightwing movie
absolutely agree the folks have it over
that Nightwing movie that can it's just
waiting for you just can that's this is
you know it's exciting when DC has
official release dates I don't like at
this point whatever goodwill they built
I still won't believe anything they say
until it's like coming out ya know like
until it's about to hit the theatres
near me oh man I think we covered
everything here everybody because we
missed I think we missed anyone super
chat here want to make sure our that
anyway guys alright we're gonna wrap
this up in literally like five minutes
because I got I got some patreon thinks
to handle right now and just so you guys
know starting next week we're gonna be
experimenting we're going to be doing
like for certain shows like my hero
academia supernatural I I'm gonna be
uploading my last full-length TV show
reaction watch along the timecode you
got a sink for attack on Titan fully
caught up on attack on Titan that's
gonna be going up some time on the
weekend but then next week starting at
one punch man one man punch punch the
one guy that's the show up one punch I'm
gonna be starting that up and I'll be
doing 10-minute cuts for the reaction
part as well we're doing 10-minute cuts
for Supernatural and my hero academia
starting up next week and then the other
shows will be just full
watch along as well so hell yeah guys
but yeah anything else that we want to
go over really quick for the next five
minutes is we got some things to get
organized on our end before my guest
shows up you know did Dan Stevens could
be a cool Batman man you really you
really on the Dreamcast hype right now
huh damn Stephens a throne names
outsider no we're talking about this
dude yes you will keep throwing out
names well people are dropping off the
the livestream so fast I'm sorry who
will be the last man standing if we can
just get it down a one more person
that's the calm person just left the
comments I want to start seeing is
instead of first I just want to see
somebody come at last and have that
truly be the last guy oh also there is a
Hobbs and Shaw trailer coming out
tomorrow and since Universal can be kind
of dickish about blocking or definitely
monetizing your video instantaneously
yeah we're not going to be as because
you know sometimes we're up right and
[ __ ] early I take about 30 minutes at
least to just make sure I look alert and
I'm sharp enough on camera so if we're a
little late to that it's because I just
don't care as much so you guys know but
we will definitely be covering it
tomorrow
okay just giving you guys a heads up
I've got I'm a little excited to check
out that sure they're on the job with
directors going at it it sounds like
Roman reigns is in Hobbs and Shaw really
I'll know it sure I'm wearing I don't
have a Roman reigns shirt do i oh Resler
woman yeah wait no I do have yeah I do
ever run the range for this one we cover
right now Roman reigns no you have got
damla name oh come on he's got like a
more apparent voice yeah Seth Rollins
said throw out of Seth Rollins her yeah
yeah we always figured it out we did it
hey congratulations on that hot dog
catch time anyway and also uh Sunday
Super Bowl Sunday get ready for a lot of
uploads guys get ready for a lot I
should play Batman
Batman and I could be Robin yeah you
should be Alfred
thanks man I have a gray hair coming in
so that's perfect should be Alfred dad
that'd be great
oh great I'll stay at home and you clean
up the cave for you oh I'm talking
comics Alfred [ __ ] you know I don't
know I'll pop in the background of a
panel and say sir a lot yeah alright
guys well thanks for being here and John
could definitely be British Josh Oh Amy
O'Neill your your fan girl over here
well well now I'm on the spot you know
it's like I don't know if I'm gonna do a
good job and then you can say don't look
at me because you know you're gonna
highlight the ways in which I'm getting
uncomfortable and I'm gonna make me more
self-conscious by doing so I know
because I'm concentrating because I
haven't done this exit in a while and
I've heard a lot of different British
folks in like art I've heard a lot of
Irish people talk lately so so like
sometimes my accents will get messed up
because of that hey see Amy likes it
I love the Scarecrow I would love to
play that character some oh man you
would love the Scarecrow interpretation
on the Gotham show as well all right
guys well we're gonna log off right now
thank you so much for being here who do
you think could be the next Batman put
it in the comments below make sure to
get stuck mine eyes today I give this
livestream three out of five shows I
would say that on blu-ray we buy this
live stream on blu-ray beyond the
trailers also a channel whoo what others
I'm Dante say anything specific
he's the bass has energy he's the best
che go watch che reacts much love to all
you guys take care bye bye now bye bye
men